[Müzik]
bu iz bırakmak iz bırakmak meselesi
üzerine konuşacağım bunu çok uzun
zamandır Konuşuyorum
hatta
1990'lara kadar varıyor Yani bu konu ile
ilgili yazdıklarım çizdiklerin
konuştuklarım Şimdi bunu kısaca nasıl
anlatmam lazım diye düşünürken
şöyle toparlamaya çalıştım dünyada
birçok şey kötüye gidiyor
ve bazı insanlar aramızdan bazıları bu
kötüye gidişi içinde bazı şeyleri
kendilerine dert etmiyorlar
iklim krizi gibi işte suların kirlenmesi
gibi kadınlar şiddet gibi
ırk ayrımcılığı gibi Ee ormanların
yanması gibi hayvanlar çocuklar Yani bu
konularla ilgili meseleleri kendilerine
dert ediyorlar
sonra o boğazların içinden bazıları Bu
dert ettikleri konuları bir yaşam tarzı
haline dönüştürüyorlar
bu tarafta da çok keyifli konforlu
zahmetsiz bir yaşam onları Beklerken
onlar hiçbir karşılık beklemeden
tutkuyla O dert edindikleri konuların
içinde kendilerini bulmaya başlıyorlar
işte bütün bu mesele bir şekliyle
yaşamın içinde bize daha güzel bir
dünyanın verilmesi daha yaşanabilir bir
dünyanın Armağan edilmesi neticesinde
getiriyor
İşte bu konuşmaya hazırlarken nereye
kadar geri gittim bu konu ne zaman
aklıma düşmüş diye baktım yıllar beni
Çetin Altan ile buluşturdu
1990'lı yılların ortalarında
siyasetteki kalitesizliği kültür ve
sanat meselelerini insan haklarını
Adalet konularını kendine dert etmiş bir
insandan bahsediyorum
evinde sık sık oturup konuşurduk
buluşmalarımız olurdu
kendisini yakından tanımayanlar için iki
tane yazısını tavsiye edeceğim iyi
yaşamak sanıldığı kadar hissedilir mi ya
da Rafadan yumurta ve limonata
internetten bulup okuyabilirsiniz bu
yazıları
İşte bu sohbetlerimizden bir tanesini
bana dedi ki bak Salim Ben 42 yıldır her
sabah bir beyaz sayfaya uyanıyorum
Akşam olduğunda kendim için olduğu kadar
toplum için o beyaz sayfanın zamana ve
mekana dayalı bir şekliyle bilgiye
dönüşmesi lazım Ben ona 42 diyorum ama
ben onu söyledikten sonra 20 yıl daha
yazı yazdı O ve 20 yılda her sabah bir
beyaz sayfaya uyandı yani 62 yıl bir
insanın ömründe her sabah beyaz bir
sayfaya uyanıp zamana ve mekana dayalı
bir şeyleri ortaya koymanın mücadelesini
verdi Benim de işlerinin pek de keyifli
gitmediği bir dönemde söyledim bunu
hayallerim vardı Ama hayal kırıklıklarım
daha çoktu başarısızlıklarım var Keyfim
yok moralim yok motivasyonum yok yani bu
beyaz sayfayı işin Acaba ben de
yapabilir miyim dedim ve
kendime Ben de bir beyaz sayfa açmaya
başladım Hatta onlardan bir tanesini
bugün konuşmak için yanına getirdim
ve
ilk yazdığımı hatırlıyorum güçlü
taraflarını demişim alt alta tam güçlü
taraftarım O beyaz sayfaya yazmak üzere
iken veya sayfa bana dedi ki kolayca
olma git seni iyi tanıdığını düşündüğün
En az 10 kişiye senin güçlü taraflarını
Sor Bakalım onlar ne diyorsa onları yaz
Böylece benim beyaz sayfalarla bir Fikir
alışverişi başlamışım
güçlü Yanların arkasından nasıl bir
yaşam istiyorum Neyin peşinde koşmalıyım
bunu bu koşuya çıkarken yanımda kimler
olmalı Nasıl bir entelektüel sermayem
olmalı neler eksik Bunları nerelerde
tamamlayacağım derken kendime Bunların
içinde bir yerde yaşam tarzına dönüşmüş
bir vaziyette buldum işte bu beyaz
sayfaların yazıldığı ortamlardan bir
tanesini burada Sizinle paylaşayım dedim
ve aradan geçen yıllarda Bunlar
meyvalarını vermeye başladı Benim bütün
kitapları bu beyaz sayfaların içinden
çıktı blog yazıların konuşmaların
yaptığım danışmanlık hizmetlerindeki
inovasyon
anlamında değerlendirebileceğim
çalışmalar
üniversitelerdeki ders içeriklerin hepsi
buralardan çıktı Demek ki beye sayfalar
bir işe yarıyormuş dedim ve yaşamın
içinde bu beyaz sayfalarla bir bilgi
alışverişi benim yaşamımda iz bırakmış
insanlarla birlikte alıp götürmeye
başladı
bu konuşma için Acaba dedim ben nasıl
bir
iki cümle ile
yaşamda iz bırakmak meselesi konusunda
size aydınlatabilirim diye beyaz sayfayı
sordum beyaz sayfaların içinden bana
caktik asının o muhteşem filmi şümit
hakkında geldi Çünkü o filmin sonunda
simit karakterindeki cakniklasın diyordu
ki hayatım kimin için nasıl bir fark
yarattı
dünyada neyin dahiyeye gitmesine katkım
oldu bakın Bu soruların cevaplarıyla
birlikte bir yolculuğa başladım ve bu
yolculuğun içinden 2000'li yılların
başında etik ve ahlaki anlamda pek de
keyifli şeylerin olmadığı halkla
ilişkiler sektöründen 20 yılıma
vermiştim Ee ayrılmam gerektiğini
düşündüm
yeni bir vizyona ihtiyacım vardı Bir
vizyonun içinden itibaren yönetimi diye
bir kavram çıktı ama bunun içinde
hazırlıklı değildim burada yol almam
gerekiyordu bir yerlere danışmam
gerekiyordu bir yerlerden destek almam
gerekiyordu veya sayfaların bana dedi ki
robertus'a gittim Robert fırtına bir
sinema oyuncusu olarak biliyoruz yapımcı
yönetmen buralarını biliyoruz ama
sandersi enstit diye bir şey kurmuş
bağımsız sinemanın Merkezi olma
iddiasını taşıyan bir alanı yaratmış
kendine ve gerçekten
bir kitapçıda 800 sayfalık bir
biyografisini buldum ve o biyografisini
Satır satır okudum
1960 yılında
yutah eyaletinde kervan geçmez Kuşkonmaz
bir yerde iki dönüm bir Arsa alıyor
1970 yılında bütün varını yoğunu
kazandığı Bütün parayı oraya 2000 dönüme
genişletiyor Çünkü Hollywood'un etik ve
ahlakı değerlerine karşı bir duruşu
kendine dert etmişti ve o dert ettiği
konuların Karşısında bir bağımsız Sinema
Merkezi yaratabileceğini düşünüyordu
tarihler 1980'i gösterdiğinde
defalarca düştü kalktı iflas etti
yolundan geleceğini bilmek isteyenler
oldu ama hiç kimseye Onun bu tutkusundan
vazgeçmedi ve bugün dünyada hollywood'a
karşı
bağımsız sinemanın merkezi olarak bir
Sanders varsa arkasında yaşamda iz
bırakmış bir insana bunu borçluyuz
Benim için de özellikle onun
düşmelerinden kalkmalarından
çıkarılabilecek onlarca ders vardı
yaşamayı iz bırakmış bir diğer insan
İlhami çok taze çok yeni kaybettik benim
sınıf arkadaşım ortaokul var liseden
birlikte okuduk ve onunla İstanbul'da
çok sık olmasa da uzun soluklu
sohbetlerimiz olurdu orada neleri dert
etmişti kendine poplizme karşı bir
direnci vardı ona teslim olmayacaktı O
an başka bir yaşam tasarımı vardı orada
ilerlemek istiyordu magazin sayfalarının
değil kendi dünyasının içinde bir ses
olmaya adamıştık yani Ama bunun için
birçok şeyden vazgeçmişti işte
vazgeçişlerimizle ruhumuzun
zenginleşeceğini dünyamızın
zenginleşeceğini ve mutluluğumuzun
zenginleşeceğini ben ondan öğrendim Ne
yaptım bilenden bu vazgeç Mem meselesini
ne kadar önemli olduğunu anladım Cebime
koydum
yaşamda iz bırakmış bir diğer insan
Merve
Afrika Cumhuriyeti'nin eski Anayasa
Mahkemesi başkanı merserinde
avukatı ama benim tanıştığım dönemde
dünyada sürdürülebilirlik raporları ile
ilgili uluslararası standartları
belirleyen bir Sivil Toplum Kuruluşunun
Onursal başkanlığını yapıyordu
yapmakta olduğum çıkmış olduğum yeni
yolculukta sürdürebilirlik ve sosyal
sorumluluk konuları benim çok
altını dolduramadığım konulardı çok yeni
başlamıştık konular ve Merve ile
konuşmalarımızı kendisini Türkiye'ye
etkinliklerimize davet ettim eksik
olmasın 8 yılı arka arkaya geldi uzun
sohbetlerimiz olurdu ve o yemeklerden
bir tanesi de ona dedim ki sen dedin
sosyal sorumluluk deyince ne anlıyorsun
Merve çok basit bir tarif verdi parayı
nasıl kazandığınız soru dedi aradığım
cevap buydu benim hayatımı iz bırakmış
bir adamdan yine bir şey almış cebime
koymuş gidip bir diğer insan Victor
ananas buğday hareketini lideri ekolojik
yaşamın kendine dert etmişti bunu
mücadelesini veriyordu Bugün Türkiye'de
ekolojik pazarlarımız varsa ekolojik
çiftlikler varsa tohum takas
şenliklerimiz varsa bunların hepsini
Victoria borçluyuz
vektör Maalesef çok genç yaşında
kaybettik
buğday Derneği için gelir temin etmek
amacıyla Antalya maratonuna
koşacaktı hazırlık yaparken talihsiz bir
soba zehirlenmesi kazasında kendisini
kaybettik ama kendisi bir dünya
vatandaşıydı ve yerel değerlerin üstüne
ve yerel kimliğin üstüne Bir küresel
bireyin nasıl olunabileceği meselesini
ben ondan öğrendim hayatımı iz bırakmış
insanlardan çok önemli bir bilgiyi aldım
cebine soktum götürdüm
2015 yılında uluslararası etik
zirvesinde yapacağım konuşmanın başlığı
gelmez yola gidiyorum şeklindeydi gelmez
yola gidiyorum
Aşık Veysel'in yazdığı son şiir
yazdıktan 3 gün sonra da zaten öldü
gelmez yola gitmek zaten şiirinde de bir
ölümü tarif ediyor Benim yaptığım
konferanste dünyadaki başta küresel
ısınmalar olmak üzere işte küresel
finansal skandallar onların arkasındaki
rüşvetli yolsuzluk dolandırıcılık gibi
meseleleri anlatabileceğim bir başlık
Bir şemsiye işte gelmez yola
gittiğimizde anlatmaya çalıştı bu Olaydı
şimdi iz bırakanların
bir takım özellikleri var
bunları toparlamaya çalıştım
bunların herhangi bir tanesi iki tanesi
değil Hepsi karakterlerinin içinde bir
yerlerde var Kimileri Daha çok var
Kimileri daha az var ama yaşamda bize
daha iyi bir dünyaya Armağan etmek için
koşturan İnsanların bu özellikleri
gerçekten yaşamı ve bizi bir yerlere
çekiyor nedir bunlar mesela çatışmalara
değil mutluluğa odaklanıyorlar
kopyalardan değil gerçek kültürden
besleniyorlar
koşturmadan zamana yayılır
hedeflerle değil sonuçlarla yaşıyorlar
tutkuları bir yaşam tarzı onların
zenginliği saygının içinde
yaratıcılıkları ile toplumun ve sokağın
sesi oluyorlar
yereli önemsiyorlar ama küresel
düşünüyorlar
dakikaları yaşam sanatına
dönüştürüyorlar
Adalet terazisini bir kefesine insanın
diğerine
için nasıl bir fark yarattı dünyada
neyin gayeye gitmesine katkım oldu
dünyada iz bırakmak böyle Karbon ayak
izi
su ayak izi plastik ayak izi bunların
ölçümlenmesi gibi bir şey değil mesele
oldu Teşekkür ediyorum iyi akşamlar
[Alkış]